unsere nächsten Gäste sind im Anmarsch
Joko und KAS und ihr könnt wieder ihr
könnt den beiden Fragen stellen seid
dabei kreativ und achtet auf den
Infotext genau und am Besten eine
videofrage und es geht ja um den Youtube
Wettbewerb secret Talents ihr könnt euch
ja bewerben Link ist hier im im im im
Video drin ihr könnt euch bewerben mit
eurem geheimen Talent und hast du
eigentlich eins geheimes Talent oh weiß
ich nicht dann wä es ja nicht geheim
wenn ich es wüsste ja von das kann ja
sein dass geheim hält was ich geheim
halte ganz bewusst ja und was ist das ja
das sage ich doch nicht ach so okay gut
okay aber ihr könnt es zeigen bei Secret
Talents hier auf Youtube und dann werden
wir mit Joko KAS auch über dieses Thema
reden und über eure Fragen also haut
rein und wenn ihr besonders kreativ seid
habt ihr gute Chancen dabei zu
sein